sometimes things happen during
post-production that results in a
complete film never being released
Studios lose a few million actors lose a
hard-earned credit on the resume and the
world is deprived of a potential
cinematic masterpiece here are some
films that are out there somewhere but
have never been officially released the
Fantastic Four before a cinematic
universe was even a gleam in Marvel's
eye the company raised money by selling
off the film rights to its characters
including the Fantastic Four German
production company Constantin film paid
$250,000 for the Fantastic Four rights
in 1983 and sat on him until 1992 faced
with the agreements expiration and
needing to actually film something to
retain their rights they slap together a
low-budget movie in under a month
Fantastic Four never hit theaters as
Marvel bought back the rights for a few
million and then demanded every copies
destruction one leaked however and
quickly became one of the more legendary
bootlegs appearing at comic conventions
big bug man big bug ban is the last
movie Marlon Brando ever made and it's
never been seen in this adult animated
superhero comedy Brando plays the
villain missus shower an evil old lady
all Brando's lines were recorded in his
home where the ailing thespian insisted
on being dressed is an actual old lady
including makeup
it sounds pretty nutty but we still hope
to see this one someday
especially since Brando told the crew
that it's the most funnies had making a
movie since 1953 s Julius Caesar dark
Blood River Phoenix plays a man named
boy who lives in the middle of the
desert becomes fixated on a married
woman there's a kidnapping and axe fight
with a jealous husband and a whole lot
of shots of the desert Phoenix died in
1993 with a few scenes left unfilmed
although director George clauser cobbled
together a final cut almost 20 years
later it's never been seen outside of a
few film festivals Gods behaving badly
based on a comic novel about God's
living in modern day New York City Gods
behaving badly features an all-star cast
that includes Felicia Rashad as Demeter
and John Turturro as Hades some of the
only things that have surfaced from this
film are a bit of the title sequence and
some pictures of the cast notably
Christopher Walken
standing next to Tudor Oh wearing a
ridiculous curly wig and a gold headband
it's hard to find a reason why this film
never made it past one Film Festival in
Italy but The Hollywood Reporter
compared it to a bad 1990s SNL sketch
ouch the day the clown cried Holocaust
drama isn't the first thing that comes
to mind when you think of Jerry Lewis
but that's the premise of the day the
clown cried directed by and starring the
slapstick comedian Lewis plays the
washed-up German circus clown named
helmet dork who's forced by the Nazis to
trick children into the gas chamber
Lewis is repeatedly valved that the film
will never be released
he claims that it's because the rice to
the screenplay were never properly
secured but those who have seen acclaim
it's because it's a disaster Harry
Shearer best known for his work on The
Simpsons is one of the few who's seen it
he's called the film drastically wrong
and remarked that it's even worse than
anyone could imagine if you say Jerry
Lewis clown in a concentration camp and
you make that movie up in your head
right it's so much better than that
is it better I mean worse if you happen
to actually see it there's really only
one appropriate response how is that
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which of these
lost movies you'd most like to see